drunker friend who like tries gimmons
everybody that they're fine is way worse
yeah she's fine she's fine she broke
into the lion enclosure at like midnight
and she's like haircut okay
she's fine you don't even know her she's
fine
[Laughter]
hey townies welcome to another episode
of
the people Town population
[Applause]
Midwestern Chicago yeah I'm from Miami
originally oh you made it yeah yeah
which is like the home of the dumb
people Miami specifically before Florida
well you know Florida's deal is that all
um all evidence is public record police
blotters so which is why they get so
much more Flack than other states is
because everybody's like Mississippi
might be worse or not know that right
Georgia could be worse Missouri
definitely where we grew up so worse
than Florida but it's just that they're
just telling everybody it's like every
family has problems but the family
that's fighting on the front lawn
everyone thinks is the one that's it
Florida is the family fighting on the
front line guys take it inside people
I knew there was a show Germany or
Florida where it was like comparing the
crimes of all of Germany to the State of
Florida
and I don't know if they still do it our
friends in Chicago who have a great
radio show on ESPN 1000 uh Tom Odell and
Mark Silverman they would do a thing
um once a week they would do like
Florida or Ohio yeah and it would be a
headline you didn't have to pick and
they got so into it they would start
picking the actual town too a couple
times Tom wattle would uh nailed the
town he knows his Ohio I mean doesn't
Oregon also offer that up whatever it is
it's super fun and you know we were
explaining to you before the show that
uh our amazing fans the way you do it is
you just uh we you and I realized I
don't have who sent in this wonderful
job uh tweet at us uh at way to go Jay
way to put that in there hey I've done
it a lot we'll resurface that and figure
it out but uh tweet Us in the show notes
at DPT podcast and uh hashtag at
danavinkhirkin at Randy's uh Squad
Brothers not right now I mean you
tripped over your own
but people all the time it's like Avatar
Avatar like I mean I joke about it but
really yeah once I was calling about an
apartment when I was moving and she went
Avatar and I didn't I just went yeah she
started laughing I'm like what if that
was mine I bet you get some great coffee
cups when you order and they oh yeah at
Starbucks Avi to make it easy if I can't
sure eat fast enough yeah and then still
it'll always say like Abby or like Obi
OB-GYN all right so we got a great story
sent to us so yeah I'll jump right into
it sent in by one of our fantastic fans
I'll start with the headline man steals
One Cop Car then steals another cop car
in bid to escape the Lucia Sheriff says
I mean I guess after you steal one it
kind of doesn't matter it's like having
kids like once you have one kid second
kid's like not as also do you think it's
also do you think for them too the
second cop card wasn't as exciting yeah
I don't think this person's dumb I think
this person's a genius
cops are kind of dumb in this story and
that's why I'm gonna get to it guys it's
like the morning meeting guys again he's
in the car stop moving it running I know
you think you're above the law because
you are the law but you came from
another time where they were like oh cop
running cop car running I leave it alone
that's not how they are here first time
shame on you second time shame on that
did you ever go to like that or have you
ever gone to like a friend who lives in
like another city that's not La that's a
little more relaxed and like yeah like
leave their door like open at night
yeah what are you doing you're inviting
in the serial killer like in my mind
well maybe they need something yeah
maybe the serial killer needs a
challenge and if it's unlocked too easy
too easy
they think it's a trap you're now in
their head all right here we go crap
let's get into it a man accused of
stealing a cocoa
c-o-c-o-a one of my favorite it Pixar
movie I know Mama Coco Coco police car
on Thursday was forced off Interstate 95
and into some woods so this is in
Florida wait but who is writing this
thing Cocoa Florida Volusia Volusia
County Cocoa Florida right I think it's
probably Florida it's like a Cocoa Beach
wrong but this listen in a sentence off
Interstate 95 and into some Woods
way too do you want to be specific about
what wood yeah
do your job if they restructure the
sentence was driven was driven off the
road into some Woods off of right yeah
then it becomes narcissistic yeah
specific you just made yourself sound
Dumber yeah you didn't know how to end
that yeah
he temporarily Got Away by stealing a
second cocoa police vehicle now how do
you think that is gets driven off the
road after in a cop car yeah another cop
car pulls into the woods and then yes
jumps out and circles back while they're
looking it's like a Benny Hill it's the
best Manny Hill
yesterday I saw an lafd
Dodge Charger it was a fire department
issued all red at lafd on the back and
I'm like this is weird that you got to
be the chief right right you're the
chief or how about like if you're
driving on the road and you see just
someone in a dark blue Explorer from far
away I like drive up next time I'm like
[__] you like what why make me scared
about like what's going on like what why
are you like screwing up the highway
like everybody's driving so slow behind
you and then you're just like a regular
person screw you all right Volusia
County Sheriff Mike Chitwood that's okay
that is a great name first of all right
[__] [__] great beyond the ark [__]
great beyond Jimmy Chitwood from uh from
Hoosiers yes all right uh division Chief
Brian Henderson I know where Brian
Henderson yes you guys would I don't
know they're like around is it Brian
Henderson in our sphere well uh his wife
Emily Henderson has done a lot of like
home like uh what I don't need to say a
bunch of people that you probably don't
know but she's like an HGTV person
he I evidently
Chief Brian Henderson where the first to
arrive after the man went off the road
in the second stolen police vehicle
Chitwood said that while some will
question how the man managed to swipe
two police cars some some I love that
they've they've been let me downgraded
let me try to minimize how there's a
couple of people saying wow a couple
people with some screws loose we're kind
of confused but that's obviously some
people might be surprised that he'd
catfished the police department twice
the situation ended with no injuries
this is the quote and listen to this
quote and listen to how much he's trying
to get in front of people who are Mrs
Henderson right this is Henderson uh
this is Chitwood all right okay nobody
got hurt nobody so it was a success
right yeah we did a great job normally
people do get down sit down sit down
nobody got hurt nobody got killed nobody
got killed the pen out of your mouth man
look nobody got said nobody got hurt
nobody got killed every police officer
and Deputy went home safe like this is
like a kid
17 year old kid who does something a
half hour after curfew and drunk and
it's like first off the car is fine I'm
fine I got it I'm fine my friends are
fine the car is fine the car is fine did
you ever show up drunk at home when you
were a teenager oh yeah yeah and like
did your parents ever did you have any
the interaction with your parents
whatsoever I do remember once actually
just being high and my dad kind of being
like we know you're smoking cigarettes
and I was like I am not smoking
cigarettes yeah I got you but you were
right yeah exactly you were right you're
telling the truth it's like the classic
acting thing it's like I'm believing in
what I'm saying and it is the truth well
the stereotypes about Jewish families is
that everybody talks about everything
and we were not that way everything was
like secretive yeah so I there was one
time in high school I came home so
wasted I left the front door open and I
was sleeping with like my bedroom door
open and half of my body like on the
floor out of my and they just never said
anything wow do you think they knew they
knew because I later heard from my
brothers but yeah no they didn't they
were talking about it behind you exactly
they're like listen to your brother look
everybody's fine no one got hurt no one
got killed everybody went home find that
night all right car is okay right [__]
would made a statement about it she's
fine she's got home okay everybody she
slept eight hours I don't know why we're
making a big deal again we always do we
did this in our act about like like the
drunk person is bad but the draw drunker
friend who like tries to give into
everybody that they're fine is way worse
yeah she's fine she's fine she broke
into the line enclosure at like midnight
and she's like hair candy
she's fine you don't even know her she's
fine she's fine
Dan we're stealing that okay I'll tag
him she's better like this trust me
she's great you'll know when she's drunk
this is fun Jenna uh all right the this
is what he said on a phone interview the
bad guy went to jail safe and no
innocent person got hurt what are you
like six years old you know the bad guy
is the good guy in this story he's the
cool one
by the way if someone's like you know
how they do in TSA like they just have
people like you know go through TSA like
to test it to the stress test like with
like full machetes and their thing and
like they oftentimes get through what if
this was what if he's like I was sent to
you by the department right he's just a
great Internal Affairs I'm Internal
Affairs
TSA like caught the machete person at
the gate they'd be like hey we call it
like because that's what he's trying to
say here at the end of the day
yeah it took some woods but we didn't
get I would think if he if he stole one
cop car sure put him to jail he steals
too it's like
I remember yeah yeah 100 deal one shame
on yeah
the crazy thing is in real life this is
a lot of how our government works like
if you're so good at being bad they hire
you to like right catch me be a
government like cyber uh cyber attacks
yeah yeah they're like being recorded
but you get so good the CIA is like hey
come here yeah like you can go in and
infiltrate people that are stealing cars
and steal them back yeah I wonder if
he's so good or the cops were so bad I
mean I think this is I think it's a
combination but I wonder if sometimes
we're just reading stories from a
30-second plot point in any Fast and
Furious movie oh yeah
how many Fast and Furious
[__]
I've seen all the best oh yeah Dan that
is I can give you all the time Idols to
the fastest I can name seven characters
in the face Ten's about to come out so
10 divided by four is math I can't do
but that's our average yeah exactly yeah
I can name seven characters but my thing
is is that I sometimes I think about
this in huge movies like I remember
watching Bad Boys and stuff like this
like a crazy thing will happen in a
scene you're like this would be national
news like a car drove through the third
story of a building and landed onto
another building if that happened in
Florida like if it was bad boys we would
hear about it here so we're hearing
about like a 30 second plot point in
Fast and Furious guys
I've seen three Fast and Furious movies
not on a plane in the theater I'm a
basic opening weekend dad and Doug
Benson's joke about the title for the
Fast and Furious 10 fast 10 year seat
belt I should have been it should have
been
fast forward fast 10 years unironically
or you think I would probably say it's a
bit of I mean it's like
you know there's certain movies where
you bring Kleenex and certain movies
where you bring Reese's Pieces and this
is uh
that's a damn thing yeah but that's you
know it's a definite pieces it's a PCS
movie
uh person behind the wheel of each
stolen police vehicle was identified as
I'm not going to tell you how old he was
okay we'll guess at the end according to
uh their Sheriff the news journal is not
publishing the man's name because why
well they because there are some 17 yeah
no no they're not raising anything right
the man was charged with arm Berkeley of
a conveyance Escape fleeing or
attempting to elude law enforcement two
counts of possession of a firearm bike
you don't need the gun you need it all
you needed for the car two two counts of
Grand Theft firearm so is this like do
you want you also well you know why no
because there's a gun
or was he because then they almost make
it sound like he held a gun to one of
them and took the car no it's like
there's a shotgun hanging out in the
back or yeah they're like
so the city of cocoa got a call about
what time about a man who was acting
strangely stepping in and out of traffic
this all start oh traffic yeah it
started we have nothing better to do so
please talk to him the man ran into the
police car and drove off so it was kind
of a bathing suit he came to get him and
he was walking in and out of traffic
weird do you think that's suicidal what
is that maybe I'm assuming he has some
issues but bad day or whatever but what
time of day what time do you think this
happened
I mean now that I know that Florida
isn't worse than everywhere they just we
just know that but still like it's hard
to undo it so my mind at Florida I'm
like noon probably
I think it's like 6 p.m I'm talking like
rush hour okay I'm gonna go 11 A.M 11
A.M get your answers in shout it out at
your ham radios because this they got to
call at about 3 45 p.m wow right in the
middle you were all kind of right though
to guess in the daytime like this was a
daytime Affair
uh she added the Department's policy
calls uh they call in for Pursuits of
high-risk crime so like this they will
they will call them in this is a big
deal like once he got off on the police
car then it was like all hands on deck
for sure yeah all right we typically
don't engage in Pursuit unless it's a
high risk felony which it was because he
took the car in this particular case he
took a police car with arms in it Dan
you called it uh so that would be
considered high risk um Law Enforcement
Officers gathered with shields and guns
drawn and a police dog at the ready like
the dog's gonna why is the dog knee
don't bring the dog
the police became struck the the car
became stuck in some woods so much
what if that is the name of this for us
yeah wait it became so it wasn't like he
just stopped in my mind that was cooler
because it's just like I don't give a
[__]
yeah yeah so then the car stuck and
they're approaching with shields
obviously they got to be safe because
this guy has weapons in in the cop car
sure what does Ben do what does he do
goes out the other side of someone uh
they gather with shields and guns they
approached the stuck police car thinking
that the man was still inside it
according to a video you don't want to
have one person just waiting by the car
right not one no not even a dog they
used to pick up to block the car in
they're like we got him we got him we
got him right but as law enforcement
near the car the man ran out of the
woods some Woods some woods and jumped
into another cocoa police this guy is
amazing so cool I mean it's as long as
it is it's not his job to catch himself
no it's your job yeah to catch him oh
he's gonna keep going he's doing great I
hope his family's proud of him I mean on
some level he's two for two yeah and by
the way like Wilt Chamberlain who
changed the way free throws were you
know done in the NBA you got to change
the way you pursue people who steal cop
cars one person at the car that's your
planet right the cops will bring your
getaways he's helping them find holes
that's right we need to change this not
everybody goes you know he's being the
change that's being the change he wants
to see uh there is video with this but
it wasn't it wasn't attached to this I
gotta uh we can search for it but I I
can't find it it wasn't attached to the
article I'm sure if you Google Guy
steals two cop cars you're gonna find
that let me Google it sure no I'm saying
our listener okay uh the man uh officers
ran after him do you say our listeners
listener uh ran after him with one
officer getting as close as standing
right at the open driver's door of the
police SUV after the suspect Hopkins
died how do you not get him how do you
not get him at that point according to
the video the man Open Door you're as
close to the open door possible and then
he just goes the man took off again
driving north in the stolen cocoa police
SUV and two lights is still flashing
some other way so he now has a blueif so
everyone's pulling over to the side and
he's done first you know how to turn it
off where a guy stole a cop car and then
responded to a domestic
hey man once I get in the car I'm a
different person
the cop
man like the car makes the man and woman
yeah that's right thank you for being
here thank you as he fled an officer on
the on the police radio advised any
other vehicle dealing with him lock your
doors so now they're saying it I think
two at the hole they're like hey if
you're dealing with this dude and you
get out of your car lock your door lock
your door they do what we should have
done they learned all they're saying is
we have the capacity to learn is that
wrong do we want to condemn I encourage
any Police Department to say you know
what we from the people who live where
we uh protect and serve they did a
little Mia culpa yeah you guys do better
we're willing to learn would you rather
the Beastie Boys in on Hello Nasty did a
song that had a verse similar to I did
it like this I did it like that I did it
with a wiffle ball bat or that they grow
as people sure they grew as people yes
so I say thank credit them for the
growth they grew twice as slow as AI
would have gone right well don't even we
can't go down that's a dumb Road we're
all gonna run to tell you about Allen
Iverson uh police blocked off the
entrance to Interstate 95 shutting the
highway down as commuters fly lined up
on ramps I'm sure they were happy oh
yeah you're commuting and now you gotta
line up while they handle this whole
thing the SUV ran off the interstate and
into the median around nobody the 258
mile marker uh Chitwood said his biggest
fear is
some Woods mile marker too 258 like
they're so specific about the mile
marker tell me the goddamn Woods that it
was nope some Woods Chitwood was the
first person to approached the stuck
police SUV division Chief Henderson uh
was there almost at the same time both
of them locked their car doors
more law enforcement officers quickly
arrived this time the man did not get
away the sheriff added he was proud of
how officers and deputies work together
no in the end are you proud you have to
say that to save face right right what
else I get I'm very disappointed this is
the kid hey Mom and Dad you should be
proud I came home you should be proud of
me but I'm telling you the truth I was
only a little bit late and not two hours
I made it home sleeping half off my bed
with the front door open in my bedroom
open my bar was very this is fine his
final quote is pretty great okay again
all he's doing throughout this article
Chitwood is trying to get ahead of the
criticism sure of course right where's
the woods
uh he'd go Chitwood said you know that's
a fair criticism
is there a butt but but no but but he
kind of goes with a butt silent butt uh
by the same token people have to look
and say you know what they didn't shoot
and kill him true no one got hurt that's
where we're at with the cops right now
look we didn't shoot and kill him yeah
so everything up you're right I'm home
Mom and Dad and so is this guy we
deserve a high five we didn't shoot this
does like verbatim sound like a speech
Brian Cox's character and Super Troopers
would give at the end like at the end
because yeah because think of him he's
trying to deal with these Yahoo
this guy this guy would seems to be or
Henderson whoever
do you remember when there's a little
dark boat there was a quote-unquote
shooting at Trader Joe's and somebody
died so what actually happened was the
cops shot inside blind yes there wasn't
like a shooter so this guy's sang we
didn't know anybody and I honestly could
have easily done that you could have
just killed thank you
probably should have we certainly do
that enough but we didn't do that too if
they had shot him they would have been
like no officers died officers died and
we protected the public all right so
this is like our new stand-up bit where
we say like we don't throw in our kids
faces enough that they were never
kidnapped on our watch yeah zero you're
lucky [__] yeah you got a little bit
Yeah down there all right we're gonna
get out of here on this so far how old
is the man
who went into some Woods stole two
police cars stepping in and out of track
in and out of track and you know what
changed protocols forever probably
changed the police force yeah lock your
door already for the better you change
it for the better how old how old and no
one died I kind of want to say 17 just
because you said you couldn't name him
and I'm like maybe his okay
yeah that's what I was gonna think oh 17
and a half yeah because I didn't give
the name Stephanie's got to be but I'll
I'll go 20 years old 20 years old 27 27
years old okay get out of here on this
okay first story almost in the books uh
this gentleman shot at your ham radios
we don't know his name He's 33 years old
same age Jesus was when he died right
it might have even been Jesus and the
next story is coming from you we're
going to find out what you're up to and
talk to you about Republican
support her and it's really nice to hear
people say my name I don't care what the
last name but the first is perfect uh
we'll talk all about that and what we
have going on on the other side of the
break it's dumb people down don't go
anywhere
hey everybody welcome back to the show
we are back with the great Avital Ash uh
you know I had the pleasure of getting
to work with her at a show and watch her
do stand up and then I went that took
the Deep dive into
um her stand-up and her Instagram which
is a wonderful follow some like killer
if you want to know how to post great
stand-up Clips online some truly killer
bits that you have on there that I love
so much and I just want to know how
people can follow you and consume what
you're doing and all that stuff thank
you I'm at Avital Ash on everything Tick
Tock Instagram Twitter and I just this
is terrible that there's the instinct to
like undercut but I do feel like okay
fine I'll just stop just just to try and
do I'm going for um a lot what's that
word you know a lot instead of quantity
over quality I don't love all of them
but but there are a few of them I've
seen some great ones and you you've done
a great job and it makes me want to see
you more as a stand-up and whatnot do
you have any dates coming up nice
um or anything yes well I'm doing that
same show that we met on Michigan oh
that was super fun because it's all
crowd work yes which is super fun and
then yeah I have a couple others but I
don't remember I could pull out my phone
or you could just follow me on Instagram
and I'll post about them great way to do
it awesome and now you did a little
thing on Barry you've done some great
acting things which is wonderful too
it's very exciting I'm so proud of you
and it's like it's great what about you
boys
um right we are end of this month uh end
of March end of March end of March will
be in Phoenix said stand up live and
we're going to be with our buddy Jeff
baldinger who's fantastic he plays the
piano at the comedy story he's been with
he came with us up in Seattle and
Portland if you were at those shows
thank you to that but we'll be at
Phoenix stand up live one of my favorite
rooms in the giant room huge room let's
sell it out we've had like some really
good numbers in the last several shows
that we've done and let's hope it's an
upward Trend and we just would love to
sell those shows out because they're
amazing and Phoenix is a great place and
a great place to do stand up so that's
March 30th 31st and April 1st and then
we're going to be at moon tower together
I'm so excited we're gonna do tag it at
moon tower we're like hosting this
little uh Par 3 golfing on on Friday
with like perfect oh yeah it's gonna be
so much fun it's kind of like you know
we do the ping pong thing and then we've
done the Foosball thing with Kelsey cook
and now we're going to do this uh Par 3
golfing which will just be a blast on
Friday morning and then we're gonna do
dumb people town so all great stuff
while we're there we do the goddamn
Comedy Jam super fun that's uh the third
week in uh April April 20th through the
20th and then we're coming back to
Minneapolis first time we've been in
back in Minneapolis in like several
years maybe five years six years so
that's happening and then we're kind of
working on the summer we might go back
tomorrow Acme in uh in May in May
Michael back to Montreal we're going
back to Ann Arbor in this in the fall
and then we're heading to we're going to
Springfield Missouri the Blue Room uh
November like 10th and 11. so all that
stuff supersclass.com dannyvankirk.com
well for all my November dates you'll
want to go to Daniel and kirk.com but
before then
uh I'll be Mentor with these guys doing
a live uh doing a living week
you know who you're doing yet or no I do
but I don't know if I can say all right
don't reveal it but is it are we excited
about the guest oh it'll be super fun
great yeah yeah and then uh a whole
bunch of stand up and then obviously
dumb people town and then the next
weekend I'll be headlining with the
grolics in Denver so that'll be great
and then on the 14th before all that on
the 14th of April I will be doing my
would you rather comedy show in Houston
Texas go to danielvankirk.com love it uh
I want to throw out there because I
don't know how much this matters I'll be
doing some shows in New York the last
week of March I don't know where great
race but then right after that I'm going
to New Orleans for the Overlook Film
Festival because I wrote and directed a
segment it was in my reel you might have
seen it of this Anthology film that was
a response to the overturning of Roe v
Wade and we'll be playing there but
what's really fun is in that short I
played a cop and I got to drive one of
those big so I'm like I know how to turn
those lights on I locked my car when I
got out of it I knew better I knew
better than that so I think everybody's
in New Orleans come say hi but most
people wanted to tie it back to the no I
love that you did I love it you know
what's up I'm basically a cop you are
basically no you have to tell us look
nobody got killed and no one got hurt
all right left it by some Woods all
right you ready for this but I survived
are you ready for story two sent in by
Joseph gacchione
at ancient wisdom d-u-m-b love this dude
that's good uh here's the uh here and
you will love this because we're all
actors at heart and we all want that
part so badly Kentucky man posed as a
dead body on Tick Tock for a large
number of days now he's going to be on
CSI he got the parts
this was his Tick Tock that he was like
I'm gonna pretend to be a dead body in
various locations all right I'm gonna
get into this Louisville Kentucky native
Louisville be there in May yeah that we
we will have just I think when this
drops we've already been there in
Lawrenceburg Indiana so that show was
amazing thanks thanks for coming out for
that Kentucky native Josh Nalley
n-a-l-l-e-y Nelly uh has zero acting
experience
[Music]
okay Kentucky native Josh Nelly has zero
acting experience way to put the guy
down right it clearly has he clearly
it's this freaking clown but he's so
natural at playing quote unquote dead
yeah we know he's not when you say
playing dead I don't think you need to
put the quotes honestly or if it's
playing dead is in quotes then he's
actually dead right so the playing dead
is the is the he's playing dead that
he's he has to play a dead man on an
upcoming episode of the popular CBS
series CSI Vegas Jay and I did CSI that
was we did the original series I don't
wanna yuck anybody's yum you're gonna
[__] on us doing CSI thanks
this feels like
this is like background work
when you enter a contest in other parts
of the country and like and you will get
a walk-on part in whatever they're
essentially giving you what are we
thinking I know exactly what you're
giving you a background now I don't get
me wrong as a boy who grew up in
Rochelle Illinois
I could have gotten a walk-on part on
Night Court okay old one new one's
pretty fun too but old one or like you
can't do that on television or any of
those things I would have lost my mind
yes but will you come to find out when
you move here is it's uh it's the type
of work for people who haven't figured
anything out yet or need money for drugs
are they flying him out though because
that's pretty glamorous the whole thing
can be
well the craziest like you won a contest
to be on something I've done a lot of
backgrounds so Dan Jay and I were on the
surprise the finale of The Sopranos Jay
and I were we were not on it but Jay and
I were driving and doing a gig like
outside of Baltimore so we flew into
Baltimore and we rented a car to go
drive to do this college somewhere and
we're driving we're listening to the
radio and someone's doing an interview
with the guy who played Johnny sacks who
I thought was unbelievable we were being
taken to morning radio to do that show
oh maybe I don't know and so we're
listening to the radio sure we're
interviewing Johnny sacks Johnson who I
thought was a great actor meanwhile his
acting process just so you know he we're
like they're like the guest is like so
why do you get ready to get into these
kids you do it so well he's like I don't
know I just listen to their line and
then I say mine when their lips stop
moving I say the line that comes next
and then I don't even like wait that's
you're not I'm doing it wrong you're not
engaging at all I mean whatever I don't
know it's his line my line his line my
line I'm like that's not how I that goes
but whatever you're fantastic but I
think he was like really mad because the
woman who played Ginny remember like who
clearly was not an actress she was like
made fun of because she was overweight
did great she won a contest to be on the
show so I'm sure he was like oh I got it
who knows who's Jenny Jenny was sort of
that Johnny Johnny that was always
always having like uh struggles with her
diet uh herself for the best that it was
always an issue for her and then their
daughter gets married and he has to get
let out of jail spoiler alert but also
work yeah
um none of this is sounding familiar at
all really this is all she was just a
larger woman and it actually made you
like I'm like you're not understanding
anything about acting you being in love
with this woman and not caring about how
she looks Made Me Love You
Johnny said she won a role and then just
they kept her on this wow okay so you
never know that's incredible yeah yeah
if she starts becoming a diva then you
go all right so I got an email from CBS
said that they'd seen me on Tick Tock
and wanted to offer the part who's going
through kicked out looking for dead
bodies
who sent that email Les moonves he
doesn't even work for CBS anymore at
first I didn't believe it but they flew
me out to California I love it it's
Spirit Air it turned out that Mario Van
Peebles was the director of that episode
I got to meet him which was great but my
guess is that he played that I'm gonna
show you a picture of him this is him
just playing dead hanging out on the set
wow right here more of an uncomfortable
map yeah it just looks like someone's
gonna wake him up it's like dead notes
get him out to the set no he's not
moving oh god oh he's just kidding
someone he's napping we worked on I
forgot what movie it was years ago might
have been Bubble Boy but someone was
talking about they
new people who worked on the crew of
water world and they were like because
widely widely regarded as like the
biggest waste of money ever and they
were like just people were just sleeping
crew members just sleeping throughout
the day of work days and they're just
like burning through money yeah Natalie
who hails from Elizabethtown about 45
miles south of Louisville was asked to
the set of CSI after the show produced
in Los Angeles spotted his Macabre yet
hilarious will be the judge of that
series of tick tocks oh that is kind of
funny sure for the past year the and
we'll get to his age later restaurant
manager has campaigned for the role of
an un alive person I love that like you
can't say dead anymore is that didn't
they already say it in I guess on Tick
Tock people will not say dead yeah and
they won't say suicide
on a live person movies or she
identifies I don't know by creating
Daily Posts at various locations around
the Bluegrass State although the
locations are always different his
posture seldom very this is sort of like
lazy planking
[Laughter]
yeah remember how simple our world was
that we just were like oh you guys at
least people plank everywhere although
this would be alarming if someone didn't
know what was going on sure of course
most often he's face down in snow dirt
grass or rocks on the bank of a river
someone's front lawn or a local park if
he's face down on your Frontline no too
you come outside and you come on you're
gonna be like what is gonna be
terrifying yeah how does he know how do
people not see him breathing like how is
he is he very good he's really good
anybody face down anywhere you're scary
that is scary actually I disagree
my time living in some not so great
neighborhoods I always had a rule face
down Fine face up Dead face up I face
down fine it just seems people don't die
face up I was always like you okay face
down I figured they were there so you
can barely breathe face down
occasionally now yeah if they were if
they were literal face down then I'd be
like just kidding more like on their
side taking a nap yeah yeah yeah so face
up always but he might be the dead body
guy from now on like right he'd get 20
year olds like the guy who was like you
can call me Ray and you can call me Jay
but she doesn't call me Johnson right
right so there was like an old guy from
the 70s who like that was the only thing
he did but he was like intentional Ray
Stevens no you can call him Ray Ray I'm
gonna be fine look it up occasionally
Nelly chain changes up his dead guy pose
slumps against crumbling rock wall why
does it have to be a crumbling rock wall
sure like that's how he died
I won't uh up in front of a fully intact
Rockwell he doesn't think he's good
enough yeah reclines or reclines head
first at the front of a set of stairs so
weird these are all places by the way
here's a here's another headline in the
story just a quote just another headline
for another story never give a gun to a
duck just that's just in there so that's
just in there for another story like
when you're looking at an article you
can click on a link to another story
that's one and I'm gonna give this guy
some true yeah or you know what but you
know I wouldn't think you'd have to say
it it's kind of like the the laundry The
Tide Pods where they're like don't eat
them you're like yeah I'm eating them
I'm frying one up check out his living
underscore dead underscore Josh Tick
Tock page and you'll find more than how
many entries with Nally in hundreds of
lifeless scenes nearly how many entries
I'm gonna say nearly a thousand a
thousand entries you say a hundred what
do you say 475 okay get your answers in
townies he is you he has 350 answers
350. all right so you're right there
you're the king such as lying prone on
the banks of the Salt River splayed out
under the Corvette museum sign in
Bowling Green or prostrate in the dining
room floor where his family enjoys the
Thanksgiving meal that's funny that is
funny that is funny because you have
really I know they know that
everything's okay so yeah that's funny
but the family Josh is doing it
everywhere they go with this guy I'm
sure yeah he's like you think I'd look
you think it'd look cool look good over
there I did I don't know
can we please not do this again when are
you gonna do it just let him do it and
then there's like people yelling like
let him do it I don't want him to do it
right now let him do it I guarantee
probably Louisville is gonna invite him
to like be dead on our 50-yard line or
be dead like school like Schools
Athletic places are gonna from the star
of the background of CSI and Josh anyway
I'd like for him to step it up and do a
little more like Harold from Harold and
mod where like the deaths are happening
the actual hanging death thank you very
much great call I don't uh like speaking
on camera he said but I can lie there
and act like I'm dead pretty easily so
he doesn't want to speak up here this is
his dream so does my teenager every
morning having done more than 300 of
these posts I've progressed and gotten
better you get better at this stuff at
first he's honing his craft listen at
first you could see me breathing or the
fake blood look really bad I've gotten
rid of using the blood and got it better
at holding my breath good that's all
thanks yeah hold your breath Houdini if
the animals that sometimes triple like
an above ground diver he often gets
friends to help make the videos
which once included a few unruly goats
and there were many videos that include
his dogs I figured out the best way to
have some kind of movement in the video
so it doesn't look like a still
photograph one of my dogs still seems
curious about what I'm up to the other
ones are just kind of wanders and then
wander offers so they're not you're done
they're not his goats not his goats
first of all that don't lay there and
also if you wanted to Star on the Walk
of Fame I don't want to be mean but if
you widened out there's probably three
or four more people doing the same thing
yeah but as far as Mark hilgenberg
Randy's showing us the Hollywood Walk of
Fame and and our guy laying there when
he traveled to California for a CSI
Vegas debut they took him to Hollywood
Walk of Fame to pose for his famous one
more one on the live videos they wanted
me to pose next to CSI Legend Marge
helgenberger star and asked you to bring
a towel to lay on because that sidewalk
is really Dirty Dan you're right but I
forgot so rather than laying face down I
kind of tear on my side and played dead
the thing so basically if you go face
down your face down and oh you're
drinking someone's ear that's right yeah
if that's what you like I don't want to
yuck someone's yum damn sure uh the
thing was the sidewalk was really really
hot it was television debut he spent two
hours in makeup and then laid very still
on a gurney for three or four takes to
get the look in the scene just right we
had to redo one take because I had my
phone in my pocket and I forgot to turn
it off
do you love this guy do you love this
guy
okay you can't get a phone call so you
guys you know I don't think I've told
you I died on ER I died I know that I
died on Agent Carter yeah on the final
season of ER I was doing background work
okay
I know through someone on Agent Carter
so it is
[Music]
and I'm doing background work and uh I
always made it a habit to try and like
ingratiate myself because you never know
what could happen right sure I love it
well we tell everybody I'm at Warner
Brothers lot and I go up to the guy
who's kind of in charge of wrangling uh
the background and uh I said hey I'm
Daniel and he's like okay
okay so if you need anything uh I'm here
and he's like yeah
and I go all right
I was like I'm gonna I'm gonna go over
there and he's like it's whatever I just
said okay so I go and sit down and this
is probably six seven o'clock in the
morning you've already you know it's a
background so you've parked the farthest
away and you've walked as far as you've
been there for an hour and a half
already and I'm sitting there and I look
over at the guy and uh I see his head
kind of uh like scaling like like
looking around scanning yeah and he
looks he looks at me and I'm already I'm
like a I'm so new to L.A I'm like a
golden retriever yeah I'm like alert yes
yeah
he gives me that oh god dude
the feeling in your loins at this point
I walk over and I'm like hey and he goes
do you act
and I go oh God damn right I do yes I do
actually I said yeah doesn't everybody
here he goes no no no no no most of
these people are either retired or
practicing acoustic guitar or like
trying to get weed money right oh okay
great and so he goes we have an actor
who didn't show up and we have to shoot
this can you tell me damn this is the
story can you take Direction and I was
like I went and sat over there
so then I go with him and so uh the the
guy he was in Erie his character had
lost an arm uh like by a helicopter a
famous television actor um he was
directing that episode and so uh they
told me like so you're going to
um we're going to come in and we're
gonna have these scenes and these are
your like lines and then they're going
to be trying to save you and then you
die and uh it was a whole like moving
like the classic ER like coming through
the shot and so I'm like you know I do
the whole thing and they shot that on
day one that was the first day of the
episode and then they were like so we
need to establish you yes being here yes
so for the next four days I was laying
in a hospital bed oh my God uh in the
background beautiful wow first day whole
time I'm like this you know like they're
like Daniel you need to just stay tuned
yeah that's it uh by the third day I
slept all day everybody you're just
laying in a bed and they ended up cut
adding it so much that you like it's
barely me coming in and then you see
them trying to save me and then I think
somebody goes yeah that guy died do you
guys want to see the makeup this guy hit
look at him oh wait you moved it you
moved it you moved wait wait dan that's
unbelievable I'm so happy for that
version of you yeah I was yeah ecstatic
yeah
so he's been uh he's gotten a um autopsy
yeah they're they're going through a
thing and so it's fun by the way dead
man can sell the phone ringing okay
of course it was a telemarketer calling
that was kind of embarrassing I love
that he had to add that detail of course
my friends and family knew not to bug me
on this possibly spam anyway although uh
Nelly doesn't plan on quitting his day
job he also doesn't plan on giving up
giving up the ghost of The Tick Tock
campaign to play Auto life parts of the
future he should be the unlike I'm alive
here like you can say you can say an
articles exactly he's actually so then
they go right after that he's actually
received several offers to play dead all
right they're immediately like we don't
care yeah I think she's trying to find
other words to not say dead over and
over including in a music video and
there have been a few low budget movies
that have also reached out for now
Nellie is weighing his options while
continuing to produce Tick-Tock videos
most of which promote the upcoming
appearance on CSI Vegas which airs
November 3rd which already ends that's
all right you can find it all right so I
originally got this idea seeing a woman
on Tick Tock posting about hot sauce
wait what who knows and got offers from
a bunch of hot sauce companies I thought
if I was created enough playing an un
alive person you can say dead
and how about that it worked I love this
guy so we got two things we're gonna
guess here okay how old how old this
wonderful guy wait no how old is he I'm
not gonna do that how old is this this
wonderful Dude I mean based on the
glance you gave me yeah
because sometimes the pictures you show
give you a wrong picture of what it is
so it makes it even more difficult I'm
gonna say he's 51 years old 51 years old
43. okay Jay 58. one of you is one year
off okay so we can all go up or down up
or down I'm gonna go 50. 44. 57 get your
answers in townies because this young
man naylie Josh naly is
42 years old
[Applause]
how many days this is my ER moment
that's right how many days did he
pretend to be dead I said he pretended
but not consecutively yeah which days
he's been doing this Force where he's
pretended to be dead he's not like he's
been the Dead Guy for how many days on
Tick Tock how many days has he post oh
man
300 maybe he's doing I'm gonna I'm gonna
say 111 days okay yeah are they kind of
adding all the hours of each one I don't
know you guys have to tell me I'm gonna
say 114. I like it what do you say 150
114 114 111 112 212. all right get your
answers in townies uh we have one more
segment it's gonna be fun uh but he
posed as a dead body on Tick Tock for
321 days yeah
seen
um it feels so similar even though it's
a different thing but it keeps popping
up on my Tick Tock where it's like
either a woman in bed or a man in bed or
sometimes a woman and a man in bed and
what looks like a ghoul behind them and
I always get sucked in for just long
enough where I'm trying to figure out if
it's like an animatronic of some kind or
someone in a costume and then I'm like
this is what they want is me to just
stare at it for long enough right it
could be an old ShowBiz Pizza commercial
you have Showbiz this is the old show
his this version of this guy who did one
thing and was booked on all these comedy
shows this is it
this weekend Mr Johnson
this all this is all
right and he got work work and it wasn't
there were no there was no Tick Tock so
what was he doing he just did it he just
did a round job
doesn't call me Johnson that's it damn
give us a little taste of what we can
hear in this quick segment three oh uh a
Lamborghini problem
that's what we all suffer from is
champagne Lamborghini problems uh Avital
Ash is here with us we're gonna do one
more segment it's dumb people to don't
go anywhere
hey guys welcome back to the show Daniel
take us home okay I got a fun little
story okay let's do it great something
by Travis Yates at the Travis Yates is
that Stephen Elton Yates
Fort Lauderdale Florida right there
uh here's the headline Lamborghini SUV
lands on roof of Fort Lauderdale home
slides off catches fire what how I know
what this is also like a uh yeah like
the beginning of Magnolia yeah like oh
the cars Lamborghini SUV
they only come in mustard yellow or like
that's a great car like lime green yeah
but like who at that point it's just an
SUV so I mean is it that much better Dan
I don't know oh I'm sure it is I'm sure
it has that engine in it right I'm sure
just go uh a Lamborghini SUV landed on
the roof of a Fort Lauderdale house
seems plausible slid off and burst into
flames before the driver fled the scene
what
so at what point though
before it landed on the roof I'm gonna
just
um I don't want to drive down this
street my ex-girlfriend lives on the
street I'm just gonna jump try and jump
this yeah so my guess is they were
driving on like a curvy street and went
off the side and came down the incident
occurred street that like is uh elevated
not a highway but just I grew up in
Florida there are not a lot of hills in
Florida am I right not no I'm trying to
I can't even imagine how you the
incident occurred just before 3 30 p.m
on Sunday could have made that again
trampoline
3 30 p.m on a Sunday on a Sunday that is
relax day right you should be relaxing
not driving cars 1100 block of Northwest
7th Avenue
Fort Lauderdale fire and rescue
assistant chief Timothy Heiser told wsvn
that the Lamborghini SUV crashed into
another vehicle and then flew through
the air oh my God about how many feet oh
so
flew so flu would be on a trajectory
yeah I mean Jason 40 feet 40 feet uh 25
feet
I'll go in the middle 33 feet okay
flew in the air about 30 feet
landed on a roof of the house right here
I don't know where that is yeah buy some
Woods
right here right here hit the tree see
where I'm pointing readers hit the tree
the tree
this is obviously when somebody said
something on camera that they put into
written forms right right here hit the
tree hit the tree went over there and
fell to the ground and burst into flames
by the way he's out of a hat on a hat
that is a little like yeah in a movie
but it's too much we got it right you
know just cut at the roof into the roof
uh by the way kudos to the house were
being strong enough to bounce to sustain
them to sustain a Lamborghini being
hurled 33 30. it's matching a lot of
trampolines
I can show you some pics that's the
problem that's the last time you drive
into a Sky Zone yeah exactly so it gets
up and then you can see after it's like
all charred the charred remains of it
well this will uh be uh in the YouTube
video this is one where the cops could
be like and no one got hurt and it would
be impressive this is insane it is a
small house so let's be honest yeah but
all the more strength a lot of strength
in that sturdy little it's like the Rudy
of houses it's just a Rowdy little fella
who's that little house The Good the
little little house that could that
could stay up
um what kind of a house you got so like
in the selling of the house moving
forward can take the impact of a
Lamborghini yes uh SUV bathrooms my
favorite person in this story just on
name alone witness Clarence Middleton
yeah great name who should we get for a
lot of things
to the queen right to the princess you
know I'm gonna tell you what I didn't
see hold on that's it let's start out
like that let's tell us what you did see
a whole lot of nothing he told wsvn he
saw someone stuck inside the mangled SUV
so he helped pull the driver
this is a quote from Clarence Middleton
he's drunk he got up and ran off with no
shoes on with just socks on just I'm
glad there was evidence because I feel
like otherwise
but also the fact that Clarence has just
seen a car go into a fly through the air
land on a house hit a tree fall down and
burst on the plane she's like that
[__] only had socks on it that
is his big thing and then he turned to
everyone said now do y'all want to see a
civil war sword yeah they're like oh no
no firefighters are well depends on
which side the firefighters arrived a
short time later and distinguished the
Flames employees of Westway Towing which
was called out to haul the vehicle away
took pictures of the aftermath which uh
you saw I wonder if it's a stolen car
because why else do you run or you're
drunk or you you've had or you're I mean
if you have a Lamborghini I'm assuming
you're not drunk you're probably coked
up yeah
you don't drive those are stolen drugs
are stolen yeah and yeah it would be
cocaine you're right it would be cool
the driver of the second vehicle yeah
this wasn't a parked car
an oncoming car with it no no I probably
rode up the front of it wrote up the
front of it and then just took off this
is a was trampoline on the other car
that bounced on top of the community
it's carrying a trampoline home 11 years
can't wait to get this trampoline home
for our kids 11 years ago we saw a man
suplex another man outside of a Gelson's
suplex what is it suplex
me I messed it up souffle yeah it is a
souffle
uh kind of hat on my head and then
grabbed him by the waist and then went
straight up with him backwards onto the
fell down on the sidewalk yes we saw
that happen two people that you didn't
know no no you really didn't know
obviously neither one of us will ever
forget that if you watched any car in
any residential area you know even in in
an arena go 30 feet through the air
you're never gonna no so there's a
there's a video that I highly recommend
watching like over so in Silver Lake
where I am there are some huge huge tall
streets Baxter is a huge Street I had to
drive over it when there were some
street closures and like you just go
very slowly over the top of it and even
as you're a roller coaster right and if
you're in an SUV because you can't see
what's on the other side you don't see
what's coming someone
took a Tesla no this is this went viral
about a year ago yeah and like just sped
it up a classic gunned it and it flew
probably like 85 cars hit a whole bunch
of hard cars I'm like dummies what are
you doing was it right oh my God it's
insane it seems like you have to try to
do that you can't accidentally bounce
off of one car onto it yeah this guy was
like idiot drunk I'm trying to get out
that's why he ran the driver of the
second vehicle walked away with only
minor injuries thank God so I know uh
Henderson's gonna be happy about that
nobody got injured Clarence Anderson uh
and nobody was in nobody inside the home
was injured either firefighter said the
house had to be vacated because of
extent of the extent of the damage
caused by the crash I mean they should
get like a swimming pool I mean what was
that you go look did you hear did you oh
I think it fell off and hit the tree
well who cares did you hear that yeah
the tree yeah look in the tree oh that's
our show Friends
and as we say uh oh [__] we gotta get
back to work
[Music]
people town